let's bring in from Salt Lake City Brett
Tolman a former US attorney and in Los
Angeles Harry Lippmann who was deputy
assistant attorney general during the
Bill Clinton administration gentlemen
great to see you Brett your view of the
case of the document production
you heard what congressman Jordan said
they're obviously palpable frustration
with the awarding of what the GOP
majority believes is the rightful
oversight role of the legislative branch
over this process that led to the spying
on an American citizen but through the
use of this FISA Court yeah it is it's
interesting to hear representative
Jordan because he's absolutely correct
they have oversight responsibilities now
I had the luxury of working in the
Senate prior to becoming the US Attorney
and during that four-year period of time
I heard the Democrats clamoring and
asking again and again for the
Department of Justice to be transparent
to be transparent give us documents it's
ironic for me to now see them saying
whoa hold up this is this is not their
prerogative they're going too far
no the Department of Justice has long
held Congress with some disdain and has
treated them as a stepbrother sister not
worrying about what they want and not
answering their subpoenas or their
requests for documents and I saw it you
know front and center Harry I think the
Democrats has for longest time were the
party that was gonna that was going to
protect the people against the
government over right reach you know the
the government you know Intel they're
gonna be spying on Americans it's it's
it's a heavy-footed stuff and we don't
trust that we don't trust the big
government because the people have
rights now we got the Democrats seeming
to give carte blush to this FISA Court
and to the way it operated with this
with this you know application for the
warrant and so forth this is legitimate
for Congress to want these documents why
are they not getting this information in
a timely fashion so a couple points
Larry I think it's right that and Brett
sort of sort of underscores it is a
perennial debate it really isn't a
Democrat versus Republican issue it's a
hill vs. DOJ issue it plays out all the
time there's this push and pull why
aren't they getting it I here's what the
Department would say and I think it's
pretty legitimate congressman Jordan
says oh it's still unredacted well yes
there were two redactions in the
document they saw today one was the name
of a foreign agent the other was the
name of a foreign country people in the
FBI Democrat or Republican are worried
why does it take the threat of
impeachment to get information what are
they hiding that you have to have to
threaten impeachment of a the head of
the FBI or another high ranking official
to get a EC to the leaders of this
committee that's wild
what is truly why so all right so again
Laura there I mean first there's the
whole corpus and the FBI's point is this
is going to take a while this point is
all the change that's a Democrat easy is
it on your I hear you on that specific
document what's the problem the problem
is the potential revelation by specific
foreign agent a specific country and I'd
let me just say one more thing which is
you made the right point it's not it's
not a Democrat Republican issue but in
fact it still does leak like a sieve and
the and the even the Chairman's record
is not so good yeah it feels burned yeah
I got a read I got to read the headline
in the Washington Post tonight I mean I
want both of your reaction here Steve
bannon's out there Bannon pitches white
house on plan to [ __ ] Muller probe
and protect Trump the first step these
people say would be for Trump to fire
deputy AG rod Rosenstein Bannon is also
recommending the White House cease its
cooperation with Muller this according
to Bob Kosta Brett your comment on that
what would that lead to firing
Rosenstein who's the deputy AG well
certainly it's not going to be without
any sort of debate I'm going to tell you
though that that that that is something
you know when you serve in the
Department of Justice you serve at the
pleasure of the president it was I was
told that maybe a
different times when I was nominated
confirmed and then served as United
States Attorney so the president does
have that prerogative
we're in dicey political times we
understand that but what we don't know
is why isn't there a more aggressive
analysis that has been done when when
the FBI has leaks when the FBI has
issues when they have presented
information to a judge a FISA judge
which we hold sacrosanct that process
when they have given information that
they know to be bought and paid for
information how is that not something
that at the highest levels of the
Department of Justice they are taking a
close measured look and analysis of and
we have we've seen nothing but
reluctance we're doing this thing called
defending the first series on the show
and we're talking a lot about the
media's role and everything and Harry a
friend of mine said you know today is
just not involved in politics said what
happened to the Washington Post though
yeah The Washington Post
used to be like let's get to the heart
of corruption in government it was
Watergate and now it's all about the
porn payment it's not about genes we
could have abused a process that allowed
the government to spy on an American
citizen doing so for purely political
purposes to prevent someone from getting
elected president as an insurance policy
and then after he was elected to undo
the election I mean that is something an
executive esta gate of Reporter should
be salivating over let's get to the
bottom of it but there seems to be a
fascinating lack of curiosity on the
part of many so-called mainstream
journalists all right so two points
first you know I think they go where the
news is you might remember in Nixon and
Watergate there's Donald Segretti and
dirty tricks
same thing with gather straw I mean
there's plenty of characters here Harry
you might have been out of the country
or what I'm saying is when the knows
about tawdry events no no when the guys
we got uranium come on what else do you
need nuclear material okay but look here
let me go because I because bring us
back to the okay quick to the
as a point look the question is not
where the the where this probe
originates but whether it's bona fide
was Linda Tripp a solid you know
credible person was Paula Jones was
Richard Mellon Scaife know they had
biases but the question for judge Starr
and the Congress is was there info bona
fide that's the question here not the
question about the poisonous tree
all right gentlemen a fantastic